For years and years I've been getting
comments on this channel from people
saying that AI content does not rank on
Google and that AI content will not be
cited in the AI search mode by Gemini,
Perplexity, and other AI search engines.
And also, you cannot build a website
from primarily just AI content. It will
grow and then it will die in a couple of
months. Now, I've been able to dispute
most of that just with one case study.
So, if we take a look at this
client that we have here, we can see
that a lot of their content was written
using AI content and it was written
using AI articles and blog posts that
was relevant to the website. Well, we
can see here that it's getting over 2.9,
so almost 3,000 responses in the AI
search mode. It's ranking in 49 places
for Gemini, 229 places for Perplexity,
and 136
places for Copilot. And for AI
overviews, over 1.7k
and 47 ChatGPT mentions. Now, if I head
over to the Google Search Console, they
now have generative AI mode. So, that
means
I can actually see how my website is
doing in terms of gen AI features. So,
you can see that this website has gotten
over 2 million impressions in 3 months.
In the last 28 days, it gets it got over
716,000
impressions and we can see that the
majority of it is from blog posts. So,
people also say that blogging is dead,
but if you take a look at this website,
blogging is certainly not dead and the
blogs and the informational content
actually is what allowed this website to
get cited and to show up in AI search.
So, those websites that stopped focusing
on SEO, stopped blogging, lost out on
ranking in AI search. So, you can see
here every single day this website gets
about 60
um 60 to 30,000
organic impressions just from AI
search mode. And we can also see that in
terms of countries, it is the top
countries around the world and not, you
know, third world nations. Let's go
ahead.
So, again, if we go over to the organic
traffic of this website, we can see that
most of them are from blogs and we can
even see from Ahrefs, it tells us in
terms of AI content level that the AI
content level has been deemed to be
high. But even though the AI content
level is high, we're still getting, you
know, thousands and thousands of page
traffic per month from these articles.
So, why do you guys think that happens?
Even though it's AI, Google knows it's
AI, why is the content still ranking?
Well, that just comes down to the
prompt and the tools that we used to
actually write the content. So, if you
take a look at this article, we can see
that it has in-depth information about
the topic with custom imagery. I've
always said this, Google does not really
care how you create your content. It
just cares that your content is
valuable, it's useful, and it actually
answers the search query. So, for
example, the search query is contact
dermatitis, right? That is a
a type of um ailment. So, we can see
here that the article directly answers
what is contact dermatol- dermatolous
look like, a complete visual guide. So,
what is it? What does it look like? The
two different types,
um you know, and some imagery here that
helps us to understand what it is more.
And this is all custom information,
in-depth information. And we can see
here that everything is internally
linked as well in SEO optimized which
are H1s and H2s. Now, I don't think
optimization is as important these days
as it used to be, but it just matters if
you have really really good content. So,
again, if we go back to another article
here, we can see that and these keywords
are not easy keywords to go after as
well. These are hard hard keywords.
Okay, so how to remove a cyst naturally?
Again, here is the full article and in
even in some cases, we actually created
custom
>> videos
>> within our content. And this was done
intentionally because we wanted to
separate ourselves from our competitors.
So, this is again what you need to do.
You need to
have the best possible page, the best
possible information about a topic and
you will rank. So, we took our time
there to create custom
um
custom videos. And also, you can see our
image is very very high quality. This is
a high quality image that we have
embedded within the article. And even if
I look at some of my other articles,
I'll show you guys in a bit, we have
custom HTML elements within those
articles as well. So, how were we able
to scale writing this content? So, if
you go ahead and look at this website,
we can see that this website has over
blog posts that's been posted over to
this website. We post, you know, about
100 now. We post less articles per
month, but we used to post 100 150
articles per month at the beginning
because we wanted to create a lot of
content and build topical authority. So,
the only way in which you can scale
writing relevant high-quality in-depth
content is by using a good tool. So,
that's where Word Rocket comes into the
picture. This is a tool that I created
from the ground up for this exact
reason. I wanted to create a tool that I
could scale my content writing, but not
generate, you know, generic
um crappy content. So, if you go ahead
and take a look at of these articles
here, we can see custom imagery that is
relevant, cover image that looks good.
We can see that now we have our GIO
optimization, which has our quick
answer, when it was last updated, key
takeaways, internal links, images look
very, very good. We can see here that
there's in-text citations as well. So,
in-text citations allows us to increase
the authoritativeness of that article
because we're
referencing other websites on our
information. We're not making up our
information. And that's the main
difference when you're generating
content, especially using AI. You don't
want to make up information. But you see
here, these images look really, really
good. We have our internal links. We
have our HTML elements.
We have our fan out questions. So, these
articles now have fan out questions.
Essentially, if I scroll down,
if I go to fan out, we can see the
questions here that is specific to these
articles, and that is what we're writing
about because we're not optimizing for
now just one key term. We're optimizing
for that specific key term, but also
questions related to that key term all
in one article. So, you can use a tool
like Word Rocket to automate your
content writing at a high level and to
make sure you're not diminishing your
quality
of your articles. And that is the secret
that we've used to be able to get over 2
million impressions in AI search and
having impressive AI search mentions and
organic SEO traffic. So, if you guys
want to go ahead and try Word Rocket for
yourselves, there will be a link in the
description below today's video. Hope
that you guys enjoyed this one. I hope
that it kind of allows you to think of
things
more
individually and take things that you
hear online with a grain of salt. You
need to go out. You need to try things.
You need to actually practice rather
than having theories in your mind. So,
we can see here we went out and we
blasted this website really, really good
content. It wasn't generic trashy
content, really, really good content on
a monthly month basis. And then we
focused on doing strategic strategic
partnerships to build this DR. But, we
can see here that this website is very,
very healthy and doing very, very well
in organic and AI search.
Take care and I'll see you in the next
one.